se você é um exemplo de superação
e quando pensa na minha vida me lembra
da sua e para de reclamar na hora
e eu fico emocionada Acho tão lindo
quando vejo pessoas como você
trabalhando estudando
O que vocês acham dessas frases
que fazem parte das vezes os pés do meu
Face e muito essas frases e outras
frases outra pergunta se às vezes até
coloco a minha capacidade
Olá eu sou Michele tenho 34 anos sou
psicóloga e tenho deficiências físicas
por conta de uma doença chamada de
certeza Como eu disse frases
questionamentos sempre estão presentes
no meu genrinho e me fizeram questionar
o tudo isso e talvez outras pessoas têm
assistência talvez não querem outras
exemplo na rua é muito comum e ainda
parar para perguntar uma coisa das boas
ou então você deveria andar acompanhada
eu deveria dar sozinha por aí
eu já me perguntaram outra doença
púrpura ou então você possa ter filho já
escutei para beber pois está numa balada
me defenda já me perguntaram se a pessoa
com deficiência tem que trazer sexual já
usei dizer ao meu namorado ele é um anjo
ou namorado
eu comecei a pensar em qual lugar essas
falas em Formosa
e a uma segregação por trás dessa
disputa como justa estão assim
deficiência talvez não esse restaurante
e há um preconceito velado Então se
chama capa assistir segunda antropólogo
na Índia Melo é materializada por
atitudes preconceituosas geradoras de
discriminação e Narciso pessoas em
função da adequação dos descontos a
padrão de beleza ele capacidade
funcional o que seria isso quanto mais
uma pessoa com deficiência apresentar em
sua característica física ou intelectual
EA sociedade capa acha que é muito
distante do que um padrão de normalidade
mas ela estará no alto de cada assistir
no terceiro trilha excluída entrevista
como inferior a P1
e assim fica difícil desafiador para se
fosse pedir atrás dos seus objetivos
Eu me formei em 2014 diz aquele dizer
especiais na adolescência como qualquer
outra pessoas estão queria ter E não era
para você ter uma dessas texto é porque
realmente é não tem ideia eu dou de
passar por 11 cursos de graduação
finalmente me encontrei na psicologia
durante a graduação cuidado com
brasileiras arquitetônico quase que
largar Por que não me permitiram mudar
para o período noturno devido a sala
está no ano passado superior com espadas
a Reitoria na época fez pouco caso não
mudaram a turma do Pooh
eu poderia ter desistido com não não
dentro do mundo não aqui nessa opção
optei por conta própria esperar um
semestre pagando tranquila Luccas Neto e
seguinte eu pudesse acompanhar outra
turma pizzaria em uma sala térrea
e esse exemplo um exemplo de exclusão
que venceu mas existem muitas outras
pessoas com deficiências fazendo as
coisas até piores
só para vocês terem uma ideia em 10 as
mudas de já é havia quase 46 milhões de
pessoas com deficiência correspondente
aquário 24 presidente da população total
é muita gente agora você sabe que
segundo uma pesquisa da raiva em 2018
apenas um por cento dessa população está
trabalhando formalmente então haja de
empresas e apenas um por cento desse um
extenso estão em cargos de coordenação e
acima
E é porque ainda nós pessoas por
resistência precisamos responder essas
pessoas precisamos exigirei tudo bem
respeito o que ainda falta para nós como
qualquer outra pessoa tem um
e existem modelo de compreensão de
resistência que estão presentes desde
sempre na nossa sociedade e através
desse modelo da gente pode entender
porque que ainda existe discriminação o
Pacífico
é o primeiro modelo é o modelo religioso
caritativo ele está presente dentro
acredita mesmo na Idade Média envia
desistência Como chego a uma olhar de
caridade de pênis a pessoa exista
cumprir sofredora o senhor incapacidade
digna de pedágio de cura
e quando alguém chega em mim e fala
nossa deve ter difícil verão assim como
você ou então que sono Nossa mas você
trabalha você não deveria ser aposentada
e os olhares de pena de nós até olhos
planejados
o segundo modelo é o biomédico e vende
por um olhar tão a normalização do corpo
normatividade diferença não é uma
crítica reabilitação da pessoa nesse
tempo a reabilitação ela é muito
importante Desde que seja possível
pessoa com licença explorar vem uma
capacidade o seu corpo o seu melhor
tentar transformado em algo que não seja
da sua natureza para aproximar um padrão
de beleza
a série um exemplo uma criança de seis
sete anos não tem os braços mas ela já
tá bem adaptada ela já brinca ela
desenha ela falando sozinha e aí vamos
dizer não mas ela precisa colocar a
própria mãe de superior porque não posso
de fazer as coisas Será mesmo que ela
precisa dessas própria sociedade está
querendo isso o terceiro modelo é o
social é aquele que o realmente acredita
que ele comprou esse Jesus gerações até
uma terceira geração que mistura o
social e ele o mestre e constitui-se num
modelo biopsicossocial
a galinha sol de uma forma geral este
blogueiro de sociais e liberam
contra-argumentar os modelos de
resistência mostrando o Cristão
independente que é deficiência não é uma
tragédia do mundo eu não sou uma
tragédia humana
a avaliação do meu corpo faz parte do
meu ciclo de vida
o modelo sociais eles mora em Capivari
está na sociedade e que nela estão as
barreiras que a desse pensa ela só
existe ele encontra e com relação as
barreiras arquitetônicas barreiras de
comunicação das ideias pedagógicas de
transporte madeira acha que regional
entre a mim é a mais importância a
segunda nem brasileira gente brasão Mas
eles atitudinais se expressa como
atitudes ou comportamentos que impeçam
ou prejudiquem a participação especial
atenção quando a gente pensa em
igualdade de condições e oportunidades
com as demais ou seja um lugar que não
tem elevador o banco
o positivo concordo que alguém falou a
decisão de não colocar duas atitudes de
alguém vou colocar esse elevadora
correto ou então coisa alguém desistir
viu rosto alguma pessoa com deficiência
desde de alguma faculdade pois se achar
incapaz Será que ela realmente encapar
ou então faltou atitude daquela
possibilidade do curso eles poderão
despertar com ela e entender o que que
poderia ser feito por ela alergia isso
percebendo quanto ainda é sociedade se
dirige a pessoa com deficiência
carregada de preconceitos mitos crenças
signo
eu passo a mão na minha cabeça fosse uma
criança que dirigem a pessoa ao meu lado
para falar comigo estão no meu poder de
decisão e autonomia
é só é possível conter caseiras atitude
nariz semanas atitude das pessoas e
consequentemente as Discover Now as
outras maneiras capacitismo própria
legendas
É mas não podemos negar já não gasta
gasolina e várias formas de não não não
única só um padrão de fazer crescer
e lá no começo a Jessy são exemplos de
superação Será que eu mereço aplausos
pois eu conseguir passar todo uma
calçada esburacada
as coisas a Cláudia por quê que juntos
para que não haja das áreas engraçadas
falta de acessibilidade na minha vida
não é um sofrimento eu tenho ainda Lúcia
fazer top de leite estava com os dois
depois que ainda tenho que aceitar
atitudes preconceituosas da sociedade
capas a luta não deve ser contra
resistência nas contra Essas barreiras
que promovem a escuridão e comentam o
capacete e a luta não deve ser só minha
olha as pessoas com deficiência mas deve
ser de todos porque enquanto houver
Barreiras haverá com a cutícula é o
preconceito a discriminação
bom e se não houvesse nas Barreiras
talvez eu estaria aqui hoje falando
sobre qualquer um
bom obrigada tá